you did a comedy tour with your husband
Moshe kasher and you guys work together
you're married and you work together on
stage in this comedy tour and you gave
relationship advice to people in the
crowd did you feel like you were
qualified to give good relationship
advice sorry I was burping uh that's
another thing that happens when you're
pregnant you burp on TV yeah we
qualified oh well it's fun cuz like I
would do like you know a half hour of
comedy then he'd do a half hour comedy
and then together we would do like the
live relationship counseling and you
know sometimes people would come up and
have like these cute little pet peeves
like she likes to she likes to sleep
with the dog on the bed and I don't want
the dog on the bed and then you know
sometimes this woman came up and she was
like she came up with her husband she's
like he doesn't understand the role of
father and I was like oh we're just
comedians yeah yeah so you know we just
try to keep it light if possible but one
person did get a divorce okay at the
club they tweeted at me that you ruined
their marriage do you have do people
ever complain about the women never
complain about things their husband does
that makes you think about your husband
yes because one of the main complaints
that women would have is you know he's a
mess he leaves his socks everywhere and
like the thing with guys it'd be one
thing if guys would like take off their
socks and leave him on the floor
but they'll like pick them up and then
put him by the bread yeah why are your
socks by the bread yeah like I was
talking to my husband the other day he
was eating corn chips and then we were
done with the conversation and he put
them in a plant and then walked away
sorry I'm laughing cuz I can totally
sure yeah and what am I gonna go put
them away where they came from no that's
what a plant is there for hold my corn
chips I talked to him about it too and
he's like I don't know I he told me he
said his instinct when he dropped
something is to run away yeah so
like a common yes yeah yeah we like to
get away from the scene
you